Speaker 1: . Hey, this is really genuinely
hilarious. Tucker Carlson bravely covered
on his program Wednesday. The fact that CNN
host Brian Stelter fired his nanny because
she wouldn't get vaccinated now what's really,
really funny about this segment? First of all,
why is Tucker firing the personal home staff
decisions of hosts on other networks? I don't
know. He doesn't have bigger and better things
to do. But the really funny thing is in hearing
the leaked audio of Brian Stelter explaining
it. Brian Stelter sounds eminently reasonable.
I never have cared about Brian Stelter. Now,
after hearing what he did, I'm like, Wow,
he really seems to be thoughtful about what he's
doing. Let's let's get right into the segment and
take a listen to that. This is supposed to be an
indictment of Brian Stelter. But I'm thinking,
Wow, he really cares about his kids.
Speaker 2: So as we told you last night,
and you may have noticed, CNN pulled its top-rated
anchor, Chris Cuomo, off the air for the crime of
helping his brother, munchkins pull someone off
TV. I've let people know ahead of time. Otherwise,
you're going to have about a dozen people tuning
in and wondering, Wait, where's the steroid guy?
Speaker 1: So over now, that's
actually kind of funny. OK, but
now we'll go from Chris Cuomo to Brian Stelter,
Speaker 2: CNN, the dwarf king dispatches unit
with the news that Chris Cuomo was being pulled
off indefinitely suspended. What's so interesting
and tells you so very much about CNN is we learned
today that the eunuch himself would like Chris
Cuomo's job or the betrayal. Mr. Barea,
Speaker 1: by the way, the unique,
I guess, is his nickname for Brian Stelter.
Speaker 2: Oh, interesting. So it raises
the question of what kind of person is CNN's
media critic? Right? We've come across audio
that answers that question. So here is and we're
going to use his name for the first time, Brian
Stelter explaining to people that he has fired his
nanny, who of course, remains nameless because she
refused to get the injection. Listen to this.
Speaker 3: You know, me and my wife both work
full time. We both like enough money to have
a nanny during the day in New York and in our
nanny refuses to get vaccinated. And so
we are parting ways with her. And it was
very, very sad that we thought we thought after
six months of seeing vaccines are all good and
Speaker 1: everybody is fine that she would
come around. He gave her six months. Guys,
it sounds eminently reasonable. Brian Stelter
has a nanny. I don't know how many kids he has,
just as I, I'm sure I could. It doesn't matter.
Maybe the kids can get vaccinated. Maybe not based
on their age. Doesn't really matter. You want your
kids to be spending time around vaccinated people.
They didn't even say to the nanny, You got
to get vaccinated today or you're gone.
They gave the nanny six
months of being unvaccinated,
saying she'll come around. We like the
nanny. We don't want to get rid of the nanny.
And she didn't come around. What on earth is the
controversy here? And Tucker Carlson apparently
thinks this makes Brian Stelter look bad.
Speaker 2: So the headline here is that CNN's
media critic dismissed, blithely dismissed as
little nonwhite servant because she didn't obey.
Speaker 1: And now do we know the nanny isn't
white? I don't know about that. But when he
says it blithely, blithely means it's casual and
cheerful indifference that is callous or improper.
The audio says it was very sad, and we gave her
six months. We said, OK, we'll get in the next six
months once we know everything that now we know
about the vaccines she'll come around and get. And
she didn't. That doesn't sound blithely to me, and
Speaker 2: it's quote very, very sad.
Well, how sad? How sad was he exactly?
Speaker 1: Doesn't sound blithe to me.
Speaker 2: Did he pay her health insurance
until she finds a new job? What is she doing
to eat and pay her rent now that she's been
dismissed by CNN's very sad media critic?
We really care what happens to our servants,
do we? When they disobey? So we ask CNN, stay.
Of course, we got no answer at all, which is why
Speaker 1: would CNN give Tucker information about
Brian Stelter's privately hired
nanny? What? What? This is crazy.
This is a story on Tucker Carlson, an
Speaker 2: answer which is We don't
know. We don't care. Tells you a lot.
Speaker 1: What an insane story to be
covering that just really makes you wonder what
exactly is Tucker Carlson's real issue here with
vaccines if there is one? Because my belief
is Tucker Carlson is smart enough to realize
that as a decision, it's a completely reasonable
decision, particularly when you give a six month
run way of saying, All right, we don't
like it, but we do like the nanny. She's
going to stick around. We're going to give her
six months. Hopefully she'll get vaccinated.
She's still not getting vaccinated. We're going
to have to part ways. I am sure that privately,
Tucker Carlson knows that that's completely
reasonable. There is no way that he's so stupid
as to think that this is really the blithe act
of an individual, but it is obvious that he is
completely captured by what his audience expects
him to be saying. And that really doesn't excuse
what he's doing. It really doesn't. But I think
that that's really the explanation because I
have a very hard time believing Tucker is this
stupid and this story choice. Of course, the
the nanny of a host on a different network is
a story. Maginnis, I started coming here and
telling you guys about the things Sam Seder
is doing with his large domestic staff. I'm
making that up. I don't. I don't know of any
domestic staff that Sam Cedar has, but you all
would rightly say, David, what? What exactly
is the news here? What are you talking about?
And that's exactly the reaction we should have
with Tucker. This is for clicks and it's working.
It's working guys. It's working really, really
well for him. We are going to be doing this so
soon. Now we are going to be doing the next
David, the final of 2021 Viewer Town Hall.
All of you are welcome to call in and I hope that
you will. Here's the the details. December 14th
6:00 PM Eastern December 14th 6:00 p.m. Eastern
Where will it be streaming? If you want to watch,
if you want to watch, the town hall will
stream on the Pacman Live YouTube channel.
That's the second YouTube channel youtube.com
slash Pacman life. If you want to participate
in the town hall, beautiful, everybody's welcome.
Wide open, we will take calls via Discord at David
Pakman dot com slash discord. Everyone's welcome.
We will also have a priority channel on Discord
for our website members. So if you want your
shot at getting on to increase dramatically,
sign up at join Pacman dot com. Not only will
you get The Daily Bonus Show, the commercial free
audio and video streams of the show, you will
get a member only priority channel during the
December 14 town hall. Let's take a quick break.
We'll be back after this with quite a program
for you today. Welcome back to the David Pakman
show, remember that we are primarily supported
by viewers like you listeners, like you people
who read the show, maybe there are transcripts.
You might just be a reader who sign up for
membership on our website at join Packman dot com.
I would love for you to do so, and you'll
get instant access to the Daily Bonus Show,
commercial free audio and video streams of the
show. Priority access to the viewer town halls
like the one we have coming up on December
14th at six p.m., et cetera, et cetera.